Italy is a nation that cherishes its
rituals
and yet even here the cost of living
crisis is brewing
for many Italians this election is
happening amid an economic hurricane
[Music]
across Italy the parties and their
leaders have been holding their final
events before polling stations open on
Sunday morning
acidic rails brought down the last
Administration the country does seem to
hanker for a fresh start people are
sick and tired of this soulless
government
they wish for a government with a clear
agenda and an idea for the future
the center right parties
might convince them
a place that has known the extremes of
Triumph and misery seems in need of
optimism
this is a country with a glorious
ancient history but a turbulent modern
one it's only been a republic for 74
years but this will be the 68th
different government the politics are
about impatience and this election has
been Guided by anger over the last
government and a desire for Change and
new ideas
[Applause]
what we have found in this election are
lots of enthusiastic noisy young
supporters engaged in politics on all
sides and Keen to reshape their country
is
Italy is a volatile influential and
Wealthy nation that now faces both an
election and an economic crisis there
are turbulent times ahead